[Music]
over the past couple years more
americans have become familiar with the
story of the tulsa race massacre
where a white mob burned a vibrant black
community to the ground which is crazy
even crazier dozens of other black towns
have been erased off the american map
not by burning them down but
by hiding them underwater don't know
what i mean well let's find out in a
segment called how did we get here
[Music]
this is lake lanier it's a lake in
forsyth county
georgia where people go swimming and
boating and fishing and do a bunch of
other lakey things but
before it was lake lanier it was a town
called
oscarville georgia now oscarville was a
thriving predominantly black community
with a church
a school and dozens of homes until the
year 1912 when a very bad thing happened
oh two very bad things in 1912
two black teenagers were accused of rape
they were tried
convicted and sentenced to death in a
single day
and after they were executed a mob of
white men
terrorized drove out or killed all the
black people in the surrounding area and
they did that until the entire black
community of oscarville
disappeared the county went from having
over 1 000 black residents in 1912
to zero in 1920. that story is so sad it
makes this story look like a comedy
after the black community had been run
off the white people of forsyth county
said
you know what we could use a big old
lake so they made one
right where the town of oscarville had
just been
they flooded the area and literally
covered up the entire
town with water this is what it looks
like
right now but the town is still under
there
the homes and churches and schools
they're still
down there and now people go boating on
top of them
compared to that this is truly a rom-com
now you might be thinking what a weird
isolated incident
but just like the rat who ate the pizza
in the subway
this story is both crazy and common
ever heard of collegia alabama it was
once a thriving black community
with a black college the first black
railroad and
literally hundreds of family homes today
it's lake martin
at least they had the decency to name it
after a black person
and if you think this kind of thing only
happened in the south
let me introduce you to a place called
central park
it's named after that coffee shop on
friends central park used to have a
black community in it called
york hill but the city of new york
destroyed york hills so that they could
build the central park reservoir
because if there's one thing new york
needs it's another place for ducks to
hang out
but if you come here don't try and feed
those ducks they are very aggressive
mess around and lose a finger now when
the residents of york hill were kicked
out of their homes
they fled to another black community
nearby called seneca village
and then a few years later new york
destroyed seneca
village too so that they could build
central park on top of it
the craziest part of this story is that
i work a few blocks away from a place
where the government
disappeared to black communities and
until recently
i didn't know about any of it you know
why because
it worked they tried to erase black
communities and they came
way too close but now there are people
doing the research so we are finally
learning about places like henry and
mckee islands which is now located
under lake guntersville in alabama and
vanport oregon which is now located
under
delta park and all of these towns
which are currently literally underwater
hey wait hold on what was that last one
old never sink that's a real place
well if we've learned one thing today
it's never
assumed something is unsinkable there
are over 100 drowned american towns and
many were destroyed in the name of
something called
development induced displacement that's
when people have to leave their homes so
the government can develop things like
dams or parks or lakes this happens to
both
white and black people but historically
when it happens
black people and other people of color
are undercompensated for their property
or not compensated at all the theory is
that
the short-term bad effects are worth the
long-term benefits for the community
but it's not fair if the long-term gain
is mostly for white people
now luckily there's a solution it's a
very complicated system it involves a
series of ah who am i kidding
cut some dang checks that's it
if you're gonna kick black people out of
their homes make sure they have the
money to stay on their feet
cut a dang check and yes you can pay
their descendants too
because generational wealth is one of
the many things that is destroyed
when you put black communities under
water so
cuda these drowned towns are part
of the black american history they don't
want to teach you
it's ugly and it's gross and we don't
even know all of it
and the more we find out the harder it
is to love this place that would do
those things to so many people
and if you're feeling this way which i
often do you can try
loving what this country could become
instead
our history may be full of pain but our
future has limitless possibilities so
look to the future while simultaneously
being suspicious of every lake you see
this has been how did we get here
[Music]
foreign